listen to this this is the vagina
Natasha hi hi do you want to put on your
or just now you're going to need your
headset you're live Natasha just so you
know did you just get out of surgery I
burped sorry did you just get out of
surgery burping and yawning oh I'm we're
gonna bring our next patient in so I'm
in the bathroom I just okay just explain
to uh Tana Tana's on here hello hi
Hannah
Tana Tana oh
Hanah or maybe she's talking to somebody
else in the bathroom explain to her what
you do uh she's got an amazing company
ybl which I always use I that's why I do
do you do IVs and stuff like that yes I
do oh you should check out ybl wow I
really should yeah you are that's where
I get my B12 and all my everything but
then she also works for another company
what do you do with a vagina what are
the some of the so I'm a surgical nurse
and I work with a lot of different
Physicians surgeons and one of them is a
OBGYN who specializes in vaginal
plasties we tighten interior and
posterior of the vaginal Canal we can
restore Hyman have you ever seen a
vagina that's just so beyond repair like
you you just you were like this is put
up the picture this is just uh not my
journey yeah we get people from like the
Middle East Saudi Arabia area too it's
pretty um and they
restore they make become a virgin
again basically yeah wait that's kind of
cool I could use that to my advantage
seriously so they fly in from Dubai and
you give them Ayman again right yeah
yeah open that's so crazy said someone
in the chat said open himim yeah and um
I have to be really careful when I prep
the skin because when I we do sponge
sticks and we have to sterilize the
inside before we start so I hang the
legs up like stirups and I have to be
now you're talking my language with my
Spong sticks because I don't want to
like break anything or any Hyman because
other than you know like yeah what
happens if you break it does that mean
you took their
virginity yeah
yeah so and what else do you do do you
told me you do something else with the
The Carving you carve the meat or
something oh yeah so um we had a patient
that like basically if the lips are kind
of sagging there's a lot of excess skin
um there below the skirt below the H as
and they can uh basically what they'll
do is put filler um and SC no I've been
getting the wrong lip filler it's a
filler that can fill up the labia lips
the laia folds labia majora on wow hon
and fluffy like a plump [__] again I
love fluffy that's that's fluffy is a
very interesting adjective to describe
the vagina but you know I'm I'm living
for that it's it's like marshmallow
looking to have a perfect um Perfect
[__] you know what I mean a pouty a
perfect pouty pillow [__] yes puffy
yeah puffy pillow
[__] plump there's so many that's the
is there any is this a public bathroom
you're
in are you in a public
bathroom I'm I'm in the locker room
right now in the bathroom can other
people hear you no I'm the only one
right now and I'm I won't say where I
work because then it you know Hippa but
I won't it's basically a procedure you
can look up and if you do want any like
consult or you can DM me um you can find
me nurse Natasha or Natasha the valley
girl I can be a little more professional
you can check out uh yourbestlife medg
group.com I love it your best life
Medical Group on Instagram can I ask you
a personal question sure like are you
are you bisexual or are you straight are
you like are you into girls
ever hold on hold on it broke out what
did you say it broke um what's your
sexuality have you ever have you ever
been into a
girl um I've I've hooked up with a girl
before so when you were down there were
you like oh I can recommend you
this no no I'm I've been married to my
husband for 15 years and I've been
working here since I haven't never
recommended anyone oh so he's kind of
like the the lab rat like he'll he'll
test your new [__] and like give you a
Yelp review yeah no I mean I like I DM
people and I say hey anyone want this
you know like come you know want your
or or the okay okay I love Bieber tacos
honestly I'm I'm so excited I'm you know
I I think I have boto everywhere but my
[__] so I maybe now's the time we do
have a doctor that does like Scot talkx
I don't know if you've heard that before
um Scot talkx is the craziest wait for
men yeah CU they scx scoto is crazy I've
been doing Kagel exercises for the last
uh well I don't I don't do them now but
I did I do them right before the summer
because for the summer I want to have a
six sack so I just I just want to be
ripped I can't what is kegling your
balls really like how do you even do
that ripped K I get a a s sack but like
how do you how do you contract I
understand how a vagina can but I don't
understand how a penis
can you have a vagina there's a proe
that you can stick in and the vagina
will do like a thousand key goals in
like 30 minutes it's
like for your you know pelvic floor yeah
and um I'm not sure but I've heard this
is off the Record okay I'm I know I'm on
the radio whatever but you're on the
radio I think some guys who like need it
tighter they'll do that probe oh in
their
butt yeah oh I have some friends who
could benefit from that I will spread
the word Friends with Benefits yeah and
um what is an
otomy so that's like basically uh before
you give labor there's the brething
canal they can tear so avoiding the
avoiding the tear they'll um first do a
cut in the the vaginal between the anus
and the Leia the opening of the canal
they'll cut it but a lot of people a lot
of doctors now opt out of that you have
to do a padal massage to loosen the
tissue so that you can avoid tearing are
there what kind of
massage what is it
called paranal a paranal massage paranal
massage is there are there P paranal
massage parlor Panera Bread a lot of
birthing like L&D nurses no should know
how to do it I love their soup sof or
tight I won't go there anymore cuz last
time I was there I had their bread and I
end ended up with a yeast infection how
did that happen well I bet she it's from
the baguette I think we should let her
go back to work go get out of the
bathroom go back to surgery what are you
what are you cutting into
next uh we're doing spine today there's
a spine dock here oh wow tomorrow it's
the OBG in okay and do you know what you
have lined up for tomorrow huh do you
know what you have lined up for tomorrow
yeah yeah I'll be in in a vaginal py
tomorrow wow wow well tell that lucky
lady that we're so excited for
[Music]
her